i think it tells you a lot i don't think
i'm you know reading too deeply into
these things
all of especially on day one what the
president start to do
really really matters and all the signs
we got from that force of an
inauguration
are really really bad now
even though we're told we're going to
get unity and peace and it's wonderful
and joe's going to bring the temperature
down it seems like they're ramping the
temperature up they were ramping up
censorship of conservatives even before
the inauguration
even while president trump was still in
office now
there were calls not just to censor the
president
or i'm sorry the former president donald
trump but there are calls to censor
conservatives generally on cnn you have
a
cnn guest coming on saying enough is
enough we have got to
kick these guys out of the public sphere
we have to turn down the capability of
these conservative influencers
to reach these huge audiences there are
people on youtube for example
that have a larger daytime a larger
audience than daytime cnn
and they are extremely radical and
pushing extremely
uh radical views and so it's up to the
facebooks and youtubes in particular
to think about whether or not they want
to be effectively cable networks for
disinformation
and then we're gonna have to figure out
the oann and newsmax problem you know
that
these companies have freedom of speech
but i'm not sure we need
verizon at t comcast and such to be
bringing them into
tens of millions of homes um this is you
know allowing people to seek out
information if they really want to but
not
pushing it into their faces i think is
where we're gonna have to go here
we're gonna have to shut down
conservative outlets first of all buddy
i don't know what this guy's name is but
say my name if you're gonna talk about
me like that say my name if you're going
to say there are some people on youtube
who
you know generally have a bigger
audience than
daytime cnn say my name you coward if
you want to kick me off
you look me in the eye when you try to
do it but even beyond that he's not even
just saying let's kick off the youtube
guys
he's saying let's kick off people in oan
and newsmax
oan and newsmax two tv stations that i
go on a fair bit
it's not like they're channel five right
it's not like they're on
your basic television on network
television they're kind of higher up in
the cable channels you
you have to go there you have to request
this kind of stuff to see and he's
saying now
and no it's too much we the way he's
phrasing it is
we don't want to shove that kind of
right wing television in their face
it's not being shoved in their face you
have to go you have to sign up for you
got to go
up to the channel right and what he's
really saying is no we can't even give
people the option
the youtube look youtube is not just
shoving it in your face youtube you have
to go you subscribe to a channel you
search for it
say no people can't have that option
we need peace we need unity and if you
don't have unity you're not going to
have peace
if you don't have people you don't have
a democracy buddy lots of contradictions
in this inauguration unfortunately
lots to dread from joe biden if i
weren't a conservative and i didn't have
a deep
abiding faith that this world is broken
and a deep and abiding hope in the
in the world here to come i i would not
be feeling good
after that inauguration if you enjoyed
that break from disinformation
historical revision and screaming about
the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
that you never miss another video
you